foreign
rescuing stranded residents in Northern
Italy
and destructive floods
families and small children trapped by
Rising Waters following days of heavy
rain the situation is so dangerous that
formula one has canceled the Grand Prix
in Imola
scientists say extreme events like
flooding and the ongoing droughts in
Spain and France are made more frequent
and severe by climate change it comes as
the World Meteorological association
warns for the first time that it's now
more likely than not that global
temperatures will rise Beyond 1.5
degrees Celsius in the next five years
it's almost certain they say that in the
same time period we will experience the
hottest year ever the most dramatic
changes we expect to happen a cc in the
Arctic where we have already seen more
than double the global warming taking
place and during the coming five years
the estimation is that that the Arctic
temperatures would be three times the
global averages there are two reasons
for these predictions the first is that
even though we're already at 1.2 degrees
of warming carbon emissions keep Rising
you can see them here and therefore so
does the Heat last year for example was
the fifth warmest on record the other
issue is the likely return of a weather
phenomenon known as El Nino which tends
to push warm water up to the surface of
the Pacific Ocean further heating the
planet the only way to solve the problem
researchers say is to sharply reduce
emissions for every year we continue
increasing the amounts of greenhouse
gases we emit that's one year lost every
turn of greenhouse gases matters in
terms of how bad the extremes are and
how you know how
different the climate will be going
Beyond 1.5 may be only temporary this
time this is a hugely significant moment
a critical threshold a common goal
agreed by the International Community
now in real Jeopardy Hannah Thomas Peter
Sky News